Nowell welcome to welcome to to
Scandinavia thank you very much um are
you easily offended not really no no I
got quite a thick skin yeah oh I see and
how are you with authority because we're
here with you know this is the world's
best chess player and so I believe I'm
here and you know Percy here he's quite
an authority and I just wonder how you
are with that that's right I'm I don't I
am I'm in the rock and roll game so we
don't really we shouldn't be too
comfortable with it we don't what we
don't really have it tonight I mean we
don't apply everybody else's rules don't
apply really which is why we get into
music because it gives you all that
freedom you don't really offer Authority
it is it was not the problem with with
you and and your brother not none of you
were the leader in in a way TSA's and I
think the prob there wasn't just one
problem there were lots of problems but
I think the main the main one is that we
just grew up and became different people
you know he went one way I went another
you know and here we are but but
becoming different people I mean you you
you you once said towards the end of
your history together you you said I
can't be in a violent rock band yeah
it's good I mean that's more than
growing apart
yeah yeah she is
it is but I'm trying to be nice you know
I mean yeah you can do that I mean we
were way past that here now to read the
reason for me leaving the band was it
had got increasingly more violent but
the reason I met you you mean physically
what violin yeah yeah those stop
physical violence not by me I have
survived by your there attacking you
yeah yeah yeah yeah well it wasn't
really there was a bit of that but you
know when they
play the rugby and New Zealand do that
dance the hacker he would do that a lot
in this video
yeah but in a violent kind of way you
know I mean but I knew he's just like
well whatever but the reason for that
was because we grew up and became
different people and you know I have my
own universe he has his and I remember
you were hailed as I mean you were
hailed as a Newland McCartney you alone
I only sort of confirmed it well I
couldn't decide which one I was so both
were okay so I took both huh and how is
that for your brother
I don't know you're not a schemer I
thought I don't know wasn't a lot of the
problem you getting all the cred the
credibility and up there yeah but II got
all the women and credibility is fine
you know but really the end of the day
well you know we all in there yeah women
really I'm greed no I'm we're not in it
for greed no no I said agreed oh yeah
yeah yeah absolutely
I won't say anything about them yeah
well I just hope I don't want to start
you know with this debates about toys
okay so I'm spending it Wow there we go
okay I will define offend you later I
will find some more some way to offend
you but please please um yeah yeah you
have you have two sons yourself I do and
and I I wonder what what what would you
teach them about brotherly love
well it's not that that ice up to them
I'm not the kind of I hope not to be the
kind of parent that would force my my
upbringing or onto them in any way
they've got to decide for themselves do
you not I mean I hope that they grow up
and not be in a band together so it
would be alright did you not I mean yeah
they could both be solo that would be
great but do they fight not yet not one
of them's for another one of them's one
the four-year-old is just working out
how he can conquer the world and the
one-year-old is trying to catch the cat
and this is you and Liam all over again
well it's a battle of wills between man
and beast you see and if you can get old
of that cart you'll kill him is it is it
true that you you considered calling and
calling
your son's Fenn the Swedish names man I
may have made that as a joke in an
interview yeah because of the football
trainer yeah yeah yeah oh he's great
he's a legend I love him smelly's he's
not here yet well he's not here now but
III I'd kiss him on the face of Iverson
I really saw you in that we loved him
Assyria ice absolutely love them but
what let's let's talk about about
manchester football because football is
i mean that's what we think of when we
think about manchester we do from well
yeah well and of course you thank you um
as far as I understand the court as I
understand there are two teams no well -
you have Manchester United and you have
Manchester City yeah we have Manchester
City and then some other team yeah okay
so this is the Manchester City is your
team yeah yeah yeah yeah the other lot
are they're not actually from Manchester
okay they're from outside the city
limits are you a football are you
interested in support somewhat ok
Manchester United so what's so what's so
good about that him nothing he awesome
either question they're winning the
league every year simple as that that's
an example they win and they really win
it again this year rubbish so so power
equals success no no but I like today
they do play good football but they are
evil everybody hates them except that
guy over there
it supports them yeah he's got more
money than sense what did you say he
said he you have more money than then
sense huh tough guy you got a rough
crowd upon yeah I'm actually thinking of
going about this off
and I learned it I wonder and you
yourself described it as the last great
rock-and-roll band
well traditional traditional
rock-and-roll band yeah so what about
the bells today well what I meant by
that was it was we came along before the
internet and before mobile phones and
camera phones and all that and social
networking and all that kind of thing so
if you wanted to see our band you had to
be there in the room there was no if you
wanted our records yet to go to a record
shop a real record shop and gone by
these things called records it's all
changed now with the internet you know
you can get music downloaded directly
into your brain you know and that's if
you even consider paying for it at all
do you not I mean and we were the last
big but we were I think will be the last
big traditional band that will ever come
out of England like that going solo do
you do you ever I mean you have done
very critically acclaimed album now
which and we are gonna hear a song from
it in just a few minutes hmm I wonder do
you did you ever miss your brother in
that studio I'm gonna miss him when I go
on stage not tonight not now you know
but when I finally get on tour because
in the studio is one thing you get you
know I I enjoyed that on my own cuz I
could work at my own pace and with the
musicians I wanted to work with but I've
never done a tour where I've been the
frontman before and I don't think I've
got I think you're I think you're born
to be a frontman I don't think you can
just turn it on at 45
you know it'll take me till I'm 65 to
nail it tonight I mean so I'm gonna
because I used to just love standing at
the side playing the electric guitar
really loud
and uh I loved it and now I'm gonna have
to kind of strum and sing well saying I
don't have to would you would you would
you consider a scheme no but perhaps in
a few years I haven't seen him for two
years
well give my regards if you see him I
rolled it
she is PJ Harvey
you